this video is brought to you by
squarespace whether it's your new
profession or just a lifelong passion
start your journey to website glory with
squarespace check out their amazing
all-in-one platform through the link in
the description below more on them in a
bit
go looking through us presidents from
the first half of the 20th century and
you'll find a surplus of icons teddy
roosevelt woodrow wilson fdr and harry
truman are still famous for being among
america's greatest leaders while warren
g harding and herbert hoover are famous
for being the exact opposite heck even
william mckinley and william howard taft
remain known one for being assassinated
the other for being so fat he was
practically a walking your mum joke yet
the most fascinating president of this
era is also likely the one most of us
have never heard of calvin coolidge
rarely makes lists of best or worst
commanders in chief outside political
history geek circles his five years and
seven months in office are barely
remembered yet they constituted one of
the most quietly radical eras that
washington has ever seen as president of
the 1920s coolidge oversaw a roaring
economy even as he trimmed government
spending to the bone when he left office
it was as a conservative hero a man
who'd brought prosperity so why isn't
silent cow better remembered today the
answer lies in a tale of excess
prosperity and heartbreak
in terms of over-the-top symbolism it's
hard to beat a future president of the
united states being born on independence
day but that's exactly what john calvin
coolidge did entering the world on july
the 4th 1872 like a living metaphor yet
this well-timed entrance would turn out
to be a rare flash of bombast in the
quiet life of the 30th president and we
don't mean quiet in the sense of boring
we mean he literally barely ever spoke
growing up in picturesque but hard
scrabble plymouth vermont young calvin
absorbed the family trait of speaking
only when absolutely necessary even the
boy's father who was a merchant into
legislature and thus expected to
occasionally talk to people treated
words like expensive chocolates dosing
them out in small doses and only on
special occasions compared to his son
though the man was practically locatious
calvin coolidge grew up so silent it was
a local joke that he was mute for the
boy muttering a greeting was a
conversation while exchanging two
sentences was like launching into a
soliloquy while that quietness was in
his nature though the boy also relished
the opportunity that it gave him to
observe as most kids his age were
playing or studying coolidge seemed to
be absorbing life lessons storing them
away in a special safe deep within his
soul he noted for example the way debt
crushed family friends a fatey swore
he'd never endure he noticed too the way
his father's economical use of speech
wasn't a hindrance at town meetings but
almost a superpower a way to ensure no
one could ever throw ill-advised words
back in his face much later coolidge
would remark of his own taciturn nature
the things i don't say never get me into
trouble yet there were also times when
perhaps more should have been said when
coolidge turned 12 his mother died of
tuberculosis sent in to see her one last
time he was merely told by his father
not to cry in the aftermath of her death
there was mourning but no grieving the
two men simply never spoke about it much
as they would keep silent when
coolidge's sister died it's back to
these twin tragedies that some today
trace coolidge's temperament irritable
melancholic and difficult to be around
but you could also just as easily trace
back to them his drive to succeed years
earlier coolidge's grandfather had left
the boy 40 acres on the understanding
that he continued to work the hard
vermont soil like his family always had
instead following his sister's death the
boy suddenly left plymouth traveled to
amherst to get an education there
coolidge was unwanted by the
fraternities forced to live instead in
boarding houses this turned out to be a
blessing in disguise as it allowed him
to gradually level up his social skills
he didn't really do small talk but at
least every sentence no longer felt like
a double colonoscopy where he did start
to excel though was in making speeches
it sounds counterintuitive i mean a guy
for whom hello was one word too many was
happy to get up before an auditorium and
wow them for 40 minutes yet it seems
coolidge's natural reticent simply
melted away in these formal settings in
the sheltered world of college he was
free to discover his hidden talents he
was also free to discover his political
beliefs one of coolidge's tutors at
amherst was professor charles garman a
guy who regularly turned his lectures
into pians on individual liberty
property rights and conservatism under
his spell coolidge began to identify
more and more as a republican by the
time he graduated it was no longer
enough to return to plymouth and get
into farming no the young man now had
another destiny one it might be even
harder to reap rewards from than the
cold northeastern soil coolidge was
going to get into politics
[Music]
normally when we do videos on presidents
who came up through party politics like
lyndon johnson or richard nixon there's
a section where their career takes off
like a rocket ship calvin coolidge's
rise by contrast was like watching a
snail climb up a stepladder rather than
the name straight for the house or
senate coolidge instead set his sights
on the city council in northampton
massachusetts where he moved after
graduation only five years later did he
bolster this with a run for the school
committee a race that he lost but rather
than shrug his shoulders and move on
silent cow went back he analyzed what
had gone wrong he tried to figure out
how he could have turned the loss into a
win when he next stood for election he'd
used that knowledge to secure his
victory for the rest of his career
coolidge never lost a single race and so
silent cal began his slow but
unstoppable rise through the
massachusetts gop he became a member of
the state house of representatives then
mayor of northampton then a state
senator and then a lieutenant governor
as he rose he began to develop his
politicals in 1912 coolidge mediated a
textile strike in lawrence and came away
convinced a pro-business anti-strike
position was the only one to take that
same year he threw his lot in with
william howard taft's re-election bid
divorcing himself from the republican
progressive wing personified by teddy
roosevelt more important though may have
been coolidge's time in the state senate
there he realized the work of government
shouldn't be passing endless laws but
actively revoking bad ones that the
state passed fewer bills while he was
said at presidents was long a source of
pride for him still we don't want to
give the impression that coolidge's life
was nothing but politics there was also
time for romance for a man as dao as
coolidge loved to be the story of how he
met grace goodhue is unexpectedly sweet
a teacher at northampton school for the
deaf silent cow one day heard her
laughing through an open window and was
so enamored by the sound that he
resolved then and there to date her they
married in 1905 leading to the snarky
joke that grace taught the deaf to hear
now she might be able to teach the mute
to speak by the time the wilson
presidency got underway coolidge was a
happily married father of two with a
solid career as a conservative lawmaker
who was independent enough to track left
on stuff like women's rights and
immigration in the 1918 race for
massachusetts governor this combination
was enough to land him the job he was
sworn in the following january just in
time for the crisis that would make his
name the boston police strike was a mass
walkout over the right to form a union
suddenly without cops the city plunged
into chaos and looting but rather than
do as everyone expected and cut a deal
coolidge went on the attack ordering the
state guard into boston to restore order
coolidge fired all the striking officers
declaring there is no right to strike
against the public safety by anybody
anywhere anytime it was such a forceful
reaction that his friends begged him not
to sign the order saying it would end
his career instead it turned coolidge
into a national hero the lawlessness in
boston had horrified the nation people
saw the police officers not as regular
strikers but as deserters who
surrendered the city so when coolidge
crushed the strike america applauded
even woodrow wilson came out in support
of him from a solid but unremarkable
governor calvid coolidge had suddenly
become the hottest property in politics
just as the election year of 1920 dawned
not that his party was currently looking
for anyone popular or principled to lead
it the 1920 republican convention saw
the affably corrupt infinitely clubbable
warren g harding handed the nomination
in a shady backroom deal angered by
these shenanigans the rank and file
delegates rebelled forcing one of their
own picks onto the party ticket as vp
coolidge was in the governor's mansion
in boston when he got the call that a
voter insurgency had landed him the vice
presidential nomination his wife grace
asked if he was going to accept i
suppose i shall have to he replied with
characteristic understatement and just
like that coolidge's path to the
presidency was set now if you want your
path to a great website to be said
you've got to visit our longtime sponsor
squarespace this is the age of creation
people are making new things on the
internet all the time you probably know
someone or maybe you yourself want to
start something online and when it's
time to move that project from your head
onto the screen in front of you and get
it out to the world that's where
squarespace comes in it's the perfect
web tool to help you turn the internet
into whatever you want it to be maybe
the hands-on type with lots of opinions
and ideas about what exactly your
website should look like if so very cool
squarespace gives you all the
customization options you could ever
want me no updates no patches no
technical bs to worry about or maybe you
just need something functional something
that works with minimal thought so you
can stay focused on the content and not
just the coat of paint well just use one
of their quick beautiful templates to
make a website that's both fresh and
simple and once you're done setting up
your website locking in the name playing
with the colors if you want well there
are so many extra features that
squarespace provides that your website
can thrive email campaigns patronage
portals social integrations member only
areas analytics commercial options 24 7
customer support everything you could
ever want in one place so when you're
ready to get started on the next project
of yours big or small it involves a
website it's gotta be with squarespace
right now you can go to squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch your site go to
squarespace.com forward slash
biographics to save ten percent of your
first purchase of a website or a domain
and let's go back to quark cal
come the 1920 election the question
wasn't if the republicans would win but
just how much of a blah victory was on
the cards after eight years of wilson's
progressive agenda after a war that had
killed 116 000 americans after a deadly
pandemic and amid a deep procession
people were simply ready for change
warren harding capitalized on this
running with coolidge under the slogan a
return to normalcy without ever telling
anyone what exactly that meant not that
this ambiguity mattered that november
harding and coolidge demolished their
democratic opponents james m cox and his
vp pick franklin d roosevelt thus making
coolidge the only person to ever defeat
fdr in a national election it was a
landslide win a sign the electorate was
ready for real republican leadership
unfortunately what they got was harding
and his dodgy mates sucking the nation
dry as you might remember from our video
on him ron harding and his ohio gang
were of the go big or go home school of
corruption in his three years on the job
they did everything from sell off the
navy's oil reserves to their friends to
steal life-saving medicine from veterans
hospitals luckily for coolidge though
they never once cut their vp in on the
action as far as the white house was
concerned silent cal was a boring sap
they'd got lumbered with the lame
millhouse to harding's devilish bart so
they basically ghosted him gouledge had
little contact with harding's team even
in congress coolidge's role as senate
president was sidelined by gop majority
leader and harding powell henry cabo
lodge it was a time of immense
frustration for coolidge but it would
also save his career by 1923 corruption
under harding had gotten so extreme
ranging from extortion to unleashing the
doj on political enemies the senate had
started taking note before the scandals
could break though harding went and died
of a suspected stroke on hearing the
news it said that henry cabot lodge
turned pale and cried in disbelief my
god that means coolidge is president as
indeed he was the day harding went off
to the great pig trough in the sky
coolidge was vacationing with his family
back in plymouth far away from any
telephone line by the time the messenger
reached the house the vice president was
asleep he was woken in the night by his
father now a justice of the peace and
told to get ready coolidge got out of
bed prayed and went downstairs in the
early hours of august 3 1923 silent cal
stood under a kerosene lamp in a
darkened room in his childhood home
while his father administered the oath
of office at 2 24 am coolidge officially
became the 30th president of the united
states the drama over he went straight
back to bed as if nothing had changed
but of course it had dimly aware of the
brewing scandals coolidge became
president just as revelations of
harding's misconduct exploded just as
during the police strike the new
president responded ruthlessly harding's
crimes were open to investigation while
his old ohio gang were purged from
government although coolidge tried
carefully at first afraid of uncovering
too much corruption in his party ahead
of the 1924 election all of the 29th
president's lackeys had soon been
cold-bloodedly dispatched from
washington amid the booming economy of
the 1920s this show of force was enough
for voters rather than punish coolidge
for his proximity to harding they
instead rewarded him in november 1924
coolidge carried over 54 percent of the
vote securing himself a full term the
era of clearing up harding's mess was
over from now on coolidge would be his
own president while his term would never
be as dramatic as hardings it would
still manage to radically reshape
everything washington thought it knew
about government
the arrival of a monosyllabilic
president was a field day for american
satirists h.r mentioned famously
declared that president coolidge's ideal
day was quote would be one in which
nothing happens but while this was meant
in jest it does get to an essential
truth not that silent cow wanted nothing
to ever happen but that he wanted the
federal government to do as little as
possible conservative to his core
coolidge believed that businesses should
be left to themselves that the states
should take care of their own affairs
and that washington should aim for
blissful inaction combine this with his
penchant for taking long afternoon naps
and the 30th president got a reputation
as a man with all the spirit of a
recently deceased dodo yet coolidge
wasn't lazy he really believed america
could basically run itself once saying
if the federal government were to go out
of business the common run of people
would not detect the difference the only
time he got really animated was where
money was concerned throughout his
tenure coolidge obsessively cut
government spending even dictating what
color bags the postal service used in
order to save a few pennies he became
one of the few modern presidents to run
a budget surplus something he called
among the noblest monuments of virtue
but it wasn't just spending coolidge
slashed taxes also got the knife with
the top rate plummeting to 25 percent
still the lowest on record since world
war one among the not rich majority of
the population federal taxes dropped to
effectively nothing and all this cutting
and light touch regulation really seemed
to work the coolidge prosperity is
basically what we think of when we think
of the roaring twenties growth was
strong wages soared unemployment fell
and money was everywhere it sounds great
and for most people living through it it
probably was yet but be lying if we said
there wasn't a dark side to the coolidge
prosperity the 30th president was so
committed to small government for
example that it sometimes eclipsed his
humanity in 1927 catastrophic flooding
along the mississippi river inundated an
area the size of the republic of ireland
two hundred thousand people were
displaced and whole communities were
ruined yet coolidge was adamant the
affected towns should pay for the damage
themselves it took the secretary of
commerce herbertova to convince him to
begrudgingly launch a federal relief
effort similarly a federal anti-lynching
bill that had been championed by harding
was quietly dropped by silent cal who
felt the groundbreaking legislation
would have infringed on states rights
but the darkest side of all involved the
thing coolidge loved the most
business as the second half of the 20s
roared into view wall street was doing a
worse and worse job of regulating itself
speculation was out of control elsewhere
the agricultural sector was in dire need
of help yet coolidge never intervened
and
well we all know where that ended still
hindsight is 20 20. it's worth noting
that no one in coolidge's time saw the
wall street crash coming no they were
too busy enjoying their great gatsby
star parties and moving jerkily to the
distant strains of jazz broadly then
life was good in the coolidge years so
good that everyone expected him to run
for a second term in 1928 and to win but
there was one person who wasn't enjoying
the coolidge prosperity despite being at
the very heart of it as his term wore on
the 30th president began to spend more
and more time sleeping long epic
slumbers that soon left him with as
little as a four-hour workday in his era
coolidge's hypersomnia was a
not-so-secret joke a strange quirk of a
strange president but in the last couple
of decades a new theory has emerged one
that could explain a lot about is one
term what if calvin coolidge wasn't just
some quiet dude who liked naps but
someone in the grips of a depression so
deep he could no longer see a way out
in summer 1924 less than a year after
his dad's unexpected elevation to the
presidency sixteen-year-old calvin
coolidge jr stepped onto a white house
tennis court for an impromptu game it
was a regular day nothing special if he
had watched calvin jr and his older
brother play their set she wouldn't have
thought anything about it but after a
few games it was clear that something
wasn't right in his rush to get on court
calvin jr hadn't bothered to put on
socks now a blister had formed on his
foot causing him to cool off the game
that boring unremarkable afternoon
nobody thought much of it it was just an
interrupted tennis match there would be
plenty more in the future it was only
when disaster struck that people would
think back to that game to that
afternoon and see the roots of the
tragedy that would soon consume the
white house within days the blister on
calvin junior's foot to become infected
in these years before penicillin there
was nothing the family could do nothing
but watch helplessly as the infection
became blood poisoning calvin coolidge
jr died on july 7 1924 a little over 11
months into his father's first partial
term as his son slipped away silent cal
sat at his bedside a locket clutched in
one hand in the locket was a picture of
his own mother who died all those years
ago and a lock of her hair he pressed it
into his boy's palm until the boy could
hold it no more his cabin jr died the
locket fell from his fingers the death
of the family's golden boy hit the
coolidge is hard both the 30th president
and his wife grace were plunged into a
deep depression as coolidge later said
of the day his son died the power and
the glory of the presidency went with
him among presidents only a handful have
lost their children while serving in
office most famously abraham lincoln but
there's good reason to believe coolidge
suffered more than any of them having
never properly grieved his mother or his
sister the death of calvin jr seems to
have simply broken him it was in the
aftermath the coolidge began sleeping as
much as possible drifting away from life
from the pain of his memories for up to
16 hours at a time he showed nearly all
the signs of major depression from an
inability to take joy in things to
viciously blaming himself for everything
that had gone wrong some days he seems
to have done little more than to put his
head on his desk close his eyes and weep
now we don't want to overdo this during
his full term coolidge was hardly
bedridden with grief he worked to cut
taxes liaised with his cabinet held
regular press conferences he was even
capable of dry wit such as when he
responded to a woman who said she'd made
a bet that she could make him say more
than three words at dinner with you lose
in short he was functioning but
functioning isn't the tame as actually
living somewhere deep beneath that cold
mysterious exterior a tiny spark seemed
to have gone out in its place came
nothing but a weariness so vast that it
eclipsed everything the loss of calvin
jr affected grace just as badly in 1927
she appears to have had an affair
possibly with someone connected to the
white house there's evidence that
coolidge found out and so we come to the
final act of coolidge's presidency in
the summer of 1927 silent cal passed a
note to reporters who'd come to document
his family vacation it simply read i do
not choose to run for president in 1928.
at the time the announcement caused
shockwaves to this very day what caused
coolidge to pull out is still hotly
debated but whatever the rational reason
it seems doubtful that the image of
calvin junior slipping away wasn't
somewhere in the back of his mind
haunting him as he would for the rest of
his life
at the time coolidge handed the baton
over to his former secretary of commerce
herbertova he had every reason to think
history would smile kindly on him he'd
overseen a prolonged economic boom that
lifted americans out of poverty he'd
pushed the international kellogg bryant
pact committing nations to avoiding war
it forged a new less aggressive policy
towards latin america it kept the us out
of the league of nations he achieved a
balanced budget in fact coolidge in 1928
was so popular that republicans tried to
get his name on the party ticket refusal
to run be damned silent cal had to
practically beg them to instead nominate
hoover not that the gop needed to have
worried who was elected in a landslide
in a large part by playing off of
coolidge's legacy so yeah it seems fair
to say that as coolidge left washington
in march of 1929 that he felt sure of
being remembered but of course that's
not what happened that october the
collapse of the financial system and
subsequent great depression killed the
30th president's reputation people
charged that he'd seen the collapse
coming when he decided not to run for
re-election that his policies had
single-handedly created the economic
catastrophe with nearly a century of
hindsight we can see these charges
weren't true there were so many
intertwining causes of the depression
that it's doubtful anyone could have
averted it still coolidge could have
done more and the public seemed to
recognize this just like harding years
earlier coolidge's post-presidency
reputation was soon utterly trashed
tragically he wouldn't live long enough
to see his rehabilitation calvin killage
died of a heart attack on january 5 1933
as america stood on the cusp between two
eras behind lay the wreckage of the
roaring twenties and the prosperity
coolidge had been so proud of ahead lay
the uncharted waters of the new deal of
fdr an era that had no place for men
like silent cow today calvin coolidge is
arguably the least remembered 20th
century president washington has no
significant memorial to him there is no
presidential library even the coolidge
auditorium in the library of congress is
named for a patron who just happened to
share his last name in scholarly
rankings too coolidge remains obscure
often appearing right in the middle of
the pack he's surrounded by other
non-entities like grover cleveland and
james a garfield and yet despite his
near invisibility silentcal has still
managed to have an outsized influence on
the modern world 51 years after coolidge
left the white house another president
came in with similar thoughts on
government known as ronald reagan one of
his first acts was to hang a portrait of
coolidge in the cabinet office to help
inspire his own conservative program
it's a sweet irony of history isn't it
perhaps the most obscure 20th century
president inspiring one of the most
iconic but then that's calvin coolidge a
man who could sometimes be small
sometimes great sometimes playful
sometimes depressed
but what he and his presidency never
were was anything less than fascinating
[Music]
so i really hope you found this video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]